i'm sure you're not allowed to talk
about it but you are in the space jam
reboot yep and that means you've been
working with
lebron james this is true now i know i'm
not allowed to ask about like specifics
about the project
but lebron james is one of those people
where i have to think
uh what kind of energy is it you've
worked with all these
top actors but you're working with
someone who literally
has the title like king king james and
he is revered and he is this force of
nature
what's it like working with him
in the uh while acting just it was it
was great actually i mean he really did
approach it like a team player he really
did approach it like
he would approach the sport because he
didn't have it i mean he's done a couple
he did train wreck
and he's done a couple other things
where he really still
you know thinks of it as a sport
in many ways right and as he does
in the game he was like always there
always ready
always prepared ready to try something
ready to just go
all in and you know at some point i was
like you know you could be a much bigger
diva than you're being
right now you are king james yeah but he
was just always the only time that he
really required special treatment is
when that huge
human being had to eat so there would be
certain times it'd be like
oh got to eat and we would sit there and
wait for
15 minutes when he would and what would
he eat he's not just having like a tic
tac
and a diet soda no it was usually tissue
paper
and he's very concerned about his
physique
no i mean he would eat whatever his
person would bring out but it would be
you know substantial and he would sit
there
and eat and yeah we'd have to sit and
wait and i was like i'm gonna start
doing that
that's important we don't do that enough
we don't
we don't focus on you know because
you've been on set you know what it's
like you know you work 14-hour days
sometimes
and if you don't really take care of
yourself by the end of that thing you
could be done
and he was you know nursing an injury
he was still putting the team together
at that time sometimes after we shoot
he'd go do practice sometimes before we
chewed it at practice
so i can't it was a grueling schedule
for him so what you're advocating
is that at any moment i should just say
i can stop anything
and say i need to eat and and then a
giant you know rack of lamb is brought
out you're coloring o'brien
i can't believe that it took this for
you to to figure that out are you hungry
now
not really
but if you would i don't like lamb i'm
not really a lamb guy
right see it's falling apart isn't
working and also it's not going to work
i'm going to say hey
i need to eat and they're going to say
well it's going to be 40 minutes
to get the olive garden to deliver oh
it's the olive garden that's your go-to
yeah bread just like just a big old
basket impress
the big